here let's do this let's go through the
people in castlemore so that all the new
girls that came yeah all the new guys
that came
literally so lily focus lily was yeah
this is like the main i mean her and
liam
who was with millie before
and they were like
going really well yeah i would say
they're probably everyone's favorite
couple yeah he was well on his way that
man yeah
i think he could have been in the
running for competing with jake and lib
it would have if liam
so first of all on predictions
we're almost right what do we what do we
predict i i thought we concluded that
everyone is gonna break except
liam
yeah and
wrong as [ __ ] yeah liam broke and
uh
i guess you could say teddy was the one
who stuck around which i was surprised
by
but yeah um
so yeah there's lily and then who else
well let's go through all them that's
what i mean yeah keep scrolling
so lily what do we think of lily thought
she was cool
she definitely was i mean i thought she
was cool she's definitely not as cool as
millie yeah i think millie is one of the
coolest
legitimately like one of the coolest
contestants they've ever had definitely
like i think she's going to be a
gigantic celebrity after the show easy
yeah
um
juliette clarice you mean clarice yeah
sorry
clarice
she
also was kind of cool like put it on
tyler super hard yeah but also there's
that weird scene that they cut in
randomly of her also coming onto teddy
really yeah just out of nowhere what was
that that was so weird oh yeah right she
was just like you know i that that i
thought there was going to be more there
because i thought oh is she just you
know gaming them both up to try to get
back into the villa yeah somehow yeah
yeah so that was definitely a little bit
sus yeah super sus yeah
um amy amy who is the conquest yeah
job done she's just a check check yeah
exactly
they're gonna vote her out yeah as a
villa
i was married so he brought mary back
yeah so he could have [ __ ] marry khloe
yeah
and she made zero impression on me no i
mean just didn't even
it's funny like some people they just
don't even show like the last girl what
was the last one yeah keep scrolling
or was she the first one on the list her
like what the [ __ ] yeah she didn't say a
single [ __ ] thing the whole time
there's like four shots of her and one
of them is her just randomly doing dance
choreography in the
uh girls bathroom yeah or
they're like powder room and castle more
and you're just like
yeah she's
she's out of here yeah
i think they like cast those people on
purpose oh and then same with her
salma talked to
i forgot who she talked to she like one
person was kind of like vibing with her
for like a day then that was it yeah
so
her her accent was crazy is she irish
scroll down
no oh yeah yeah dublin
salma has selma here has never been in
love
geez
onto the tooth on the dudes and we had
some jackson
[ __ ] insane name
sam jackson
some jackson this face is
what
i don't know man he's just got like new
main vibe
it just like kind of reminds me of new
main i can't
he put a finger on it it's just a
similar vibe man i'm an actor yeah yeah
all right
i'm here i'm acting
i'm acting like i like faye
conor mcgregor's stunt devil this kid
dale scroll down dude
the funniest part is dude how much chloe
hated his [ __ ] chains i know i'm like
that's what you hate never mind that
this dude went to the 3d printing shop
and was like make me look like conor
mcgregor i want the same teeth i need
you to restructure my face
are absurd yeah
super white like you know like
i just i love when they overdo veneers
yeah
and they just like it almost looks worse
than it looks like donkey teeth just
like this
yeah
way too way too perfect bro
that [ __ ] tattoo on his chest is i
know insane i just want to know at what
point he chose to look like this
like did connor start his career and
then he goes i want to get all these
tattoos or
you know was he always looking like this
and he's like what the [ __ ] conor
mcgregor stole my whole swag yeah
where's he from scroll down
glasgow all right so
then we got jack that guy again
real race you know what i i've said it
before i'll say it again race car
drivers are built like worms
is he a race car driver yeah he's a race
car driver most of them are not ripped
like that like now fair play to him yeah
he's probably really strong yeah really
strong okay
because of driving yeah like driving you
have to have a certain like a unique
kind of strength right but it's not
looking good strength yeah like he could
probably if
he'd probably take like a
400 pound
steering wheel and just like
pull that no problem for like an hour
straight whereas most of us would gas
but that's just how he looks yeah
scroll down i want to see if they
mention what team erases for
um
they don't say so i guess now
oh now he's a coach
well still
nice
um then medi i looked up the soccer team
he plays for here i forget the name but
he played football here mls uh oh yeah i
don't even know if it's mls but i think
he plays like the like
the team he plays for here is some
really british
oriented name gotcha
here just
it doesn't matter in the thing
so yeah i mean
jack medy and this guy this
guy scared the [ __ ] out of me
[Music]
okay i don't want to be mean
what would be mean
okay he looked like mr tumnus from
narnia yeah
yeah yeah
like i half expected this dude to be not
centaur but the other one where it's
like the the donkey legs okay
like look at mr tumnus
just search that that's such an obscure
ass reference like
like he kind of looks like the duke from
charlie's angels the bad guy oh the one
who sniffs hair yeah like damn
this is what he reminded me of
yeah okay fair it's it's not really the
facial it's not really like the same
face
man they give this search to the
charlie's angels bad guy they give this
guy crazy roles man
i think i feel like
what is that damn british show this dude
yeah definitely definitely that vibe
definitely that vibe
you know he looks like he looks like
someone's brother in peaky blinders okay
you know like yeah yeah yeah accent does
it yes he does yeah
like just
menace from 1920s england yeah i know
where is he i thought he was scottish
maybe
glasgow where is glasgow
he just like he's got a really intense
like gaze and he does that smile and so
every time the camera like kind of
punched in on him he'd be like
[Laughter]
and i'm like ah [ __ ]
get that guy off the show man where's
glasgow hold on it is scotland yeah oh
so
oh yeah we did that remember we did we
did do a show yeah
so dale will be really offended that i
said he looks like conor mcgregor yeah
yeah i don't [ __ ] with no irish
yeah this dude
oh yeah and then matthew mcnabb which
which
made me really uncomfortable when
when kaz like saw the postcard yeah and
so she starts coming on to this guy or
sort of not really and he kind of
i don't know he planted that one kiss on
her that i was like i don't think she
was ready for that and i don't think she
really yeah was super into it yeah he's
kind of going in hot yeah a little bit
weird yeah i don't know
also he has the weirdest accent ever six
foot six thanks dude
just in case you wanted to keep talking
[ __ ] he's 66 yeah
so he lived in cali for two years okay
so do you ever notice like he sounds
like
like 20 of his sentence sounds american
no way really i mean it just that's how
it comes across to me he's just like
man i'm really craving a breakfast
burrito right now
like a breakfast burrito
fair play to him fair play to him
fair play to him but honestly a lot
yeah i don't know it's just there's like
every other word feels sort of american
he's got such a weirdo do you want to
kiss us
[Laughter]
see those are all the dudes they didn't
really
they all just kind of seem like
surrogates for all the ladies emotions
yeah you know like they just kind of put
some in there and let them incubate and
then they're gonna figure out what they
want yeah